il est imposant et bourru sa voix est
reconnaissable entre toutes voici
maintenant l'invité des cinq dernières
minutes
cet invité c'est michel galabru
bonjour merci vraiment d'être avec nous
sur le plateau du 13 heures de france 2
puisque la journée est importante pour
une vie commencée ce soir une pièce très
drôle
intitulé les chaussettes opus 124 vous
êtes en scène avec un autre monstre
sacré gérard desarthe c'est au théâtre
des mathurins à partir de ce soir
donc la première chose qui est frappante
c'est justement ce duo très inattendue
entre vous et gérard desarthe j'ai lu
quelque part ça peut vous vous étiez
d'ailleurs c'est la rencontre d' hamlet
et le gendarme de saint tropez
ah oui c'est vrai et ben c'est vrai et
c'est fou en même temps parce que j'ai
joué beaucoup de textes classiques geste
et s'étend la commune française trois
ans étaient dopés tous les étés avec
lessivage de monter jugement du
classique donc des grands textes mais je
suis pour les gens je suis le type et le
clip i sayad il me conforme même avec
nos sites web 2 com
cruchot je ne sais quoi même dans le
désert une fois le mrap l'oasis les
petits arbres corrézien ya moyen c'est
comme ça il faut pas s'en plaindre parce
que ça me permet de au fond de jouer des
textes d'el jadida pts et alors
j'imagine que la rencontre avec sartre
sartre vous a beaucoup plu et c'est
d'autant plus intéressant que en fait
les deux rôles que vous jouez sur scène
et ils vous ressemblent un petit peu un
petit peu oui oui l'auteur dit qu'il n'a
pas pensé à nommer c'est curieux parce
que vraiment il ya et il y avait des
choses
par exemple moi je je je je suis un peu
un cabot bois dans le dans la pièce je
suis à cabourg cabot si cabot un peu
vaniteux un peu m'as-tu-vu un peu
content d'être connue d'être reconnus
quoi et ça je jette un peu triste parce
que quand on pense que on est oublier
très rapidement bon ce sont des vanités
tu peux insignifiante et pas de charte
lui d'un parcours différents et je crois
que ça tient à lui n'a pas voulu et
c'est tout à son honneur jouer les
petits textes des petites choses et elle
a joué avec de très grands metteurs en
scène
l'applet comme double citer d'autres
shakespeare le roi lear to save et puis
brusquement il est confronté à moi et
c'est un homme que je redoutais un peu
parce que c'était pas on se dit c'est
pas la tasse de thé ouais et alors qu'on
s'entend très bien
c'est un homme charmant beaucoup plus
plat du mot beaucoup plus que je ne le
pensais quoi alors on va te cite
regardez un extrait parce qu'il faut un
peu expliqué la pièce aussi vous êtes
tous les deux sur scène vous êtes deux
comédiens un peu clown dans la pièce
nous essayer de monter un spectacle est
évidemment il ya entre vous des moments
de crispation on va dire chacun campant
sur son personnage donc on va regarder
un moment où gérard desarthe veux vous
donner des conseils et vous dirigez et
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire c'est très
bien l'important c'est que vous donniez
bien le sentiment d'enfoncer un clou un
groupe où me taper sur la tête très fort
vous enfoncer un clou alors fait loi
non mais tapait vraiment pas bon
d'exagérer le mouvement on met plus
chaudes non je vous fais risques via
massa ne craint rien et visez bien le
haut du crâne croyez vraiment qu'on va
innover las mais il ne s'agit pas digne
j'avais vu j'étais d'accord pour que
plus de livres la vie mais après d'abord
il veut donner votre avis mais pas avant
après les bons sentiments en place non
non voilà donc cet extrait est ce qu ils
s'adorent où est ce qu'ils se détestent
ces deux comédiens dans la pièce on ne
s'aime pas puis enfin ce serait con su
passer ça existe c'est un buteur en
selle lui un peu intello mouscron
loisirs connu ça faisait alors et on a
mené au nom des états côtiers simple on
doit lire le texte poétique de grands
poètes comme la forme comme vini comme
comme rimbaud et lui il fait une mise en
scène
il veut nous mettre en clown pour faire
ça vous comprenez bien les idées
saugrenues mois une fois julio metteurs
en scène comme ça il m'avait engagé pour
un jouet du labiche et il a dit que
c'était du brunch
je suis parti d'avenir mail qui
critiquent à ce titre en bref si bungie
ça va ça fait rien gagné la critique de
façon différente
il ya les metteurs en scène comme ça
qu'ils sont dans l'esprit tire-bouchonné
ou eti voile et puis ils font des
relectures ses 10 ans la pièce quand on
n'est pas sûr de son talent et ben on
remonte des auteurs consacrent l on en
fait une relecture une autre version 1
alors serge les textes aussi sur les
préjugés qu'on allait les uns par
rapport aux autres est-ce que vous en
avez souffert vous dans votre vie de
comédien de préjugés puisque vous l'avez
dit vous avez fait la colonie française
et pourtant on vous voit toujours comme
le gendarme de saint tropez
ben oui forcément il ya des gens qui ne
ne vous estiment pas qu'ils nous
engagerons jamais parce que ils ont une
une photo de vous
c'est un pli mais vous êtes un débile
pour eux parce qu'ils n'aiment pas ce
genre de théâtre
bon on les comprend où le cinéma est
pour eux et nous engagerons jamais ils
ont osé vous voir comme ça vous voit le
père du clown savez quand j'ai joué
spécial section spéciale de costa gavras
est quand même un grand metteur en scène
il a été attaqué costa gravas c'était
tout un truc à câble parce qu'ils
avaient engagé des ringards un élément
de langage
j'étais alors le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que vous ne l'êtes pas et que
maintenant la profession vous considère
vraiment comme un grand comédien euros
de théâtre de cinéma lois parfois des
films de gendarmes à saint tropez
vous jouez ce soir pour la première fois
mais bien des choses qui m'intéressent
beaucoup est-ce que vous michel galabru
vous avez encore le trac
oui ah ça oui parce que il ya du
trackball à plusieurs impasses que il ya
un travail de mémoire
on a beau savoir son texte façon parce
qu'on l'apprend l'apprend jeudi vous
vous présenter quelqu'un dans la rue
vous connaissez un certain de votre
cousin nous avons jour comment vas tu es
bien se présente c'est le trou de
mémoire et mais pourquoi voulez vous que
ça n'arrive pas sur une scène de théâtre
ça arrive
et alors on a la hantise de deux trous
de mémoire
la hantise ça devient magna les gens qui
ont arrêté le métier à cause de sa mort
et schwendi fernand ledoux et les autres
tracés koala par le trac c'est la peur
de te mauvais ça évidemment ça vous pas
ennuis comme s'il fait le trait dessus
ah oui des poètes repas bon quoi et dans
ces cas là vous faites pas pour vous
détendre juste avant ce que vous allez
faire ce soir
la feria pas il n'ya pas le seuil des 2
ne se libérer mais ça ne passe pas quoi
la nuit est très mauvaise qui précède
très mal dormi cette nuit très mauvaise
moi je veux être tellement le trac une
fois que j'avais un poisson rouge il a
sauté dans la nuit les policiers tués
c'est tellement nervosité dans la pièce
est vrai le chose juste du poisson était
très bien
il a sauté il s'est tu es bon en tout
cas j'imagine que
ce soir ce sera très bien j'en suis même
si c'est au théâtre des mathurins oui
voilà avec gérard desarthe dans les
chaussettes opus 124 première ce soir
j'imagine ça va durer pendant des
semaines
ah oui sur les durs merci à vous
beaucoup aussi bout et on ne vous dit
pas ce qu'il ne faut pas dire un
comédien jeu savant c'est la fin de ce
journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi